my dad joined Starfleet because he  believed in it  I joined on a dare you joined to see if  you could live up to him  you spent all this time trying to be  your father  not a wondering just what it means to be  you  it isn't uncommon you know it's easy to  get lost  the vastness of space  there's only your stuff your sheep  you're cool I really want to head back  out there huh  what the hell is this  they're boarding us  Brandon ship  I know why you're here why we are all  here  our captain will come to us mercy will  be the last thing on his mind I am  fear of death easy illogical  fear of death is what eats us alive  everyone who goes there he kills that's  her friends are there we can't just  leave him behind  Shuji starts your strength it's a  weakness I think you're under estimating  humanity hold on to something  hurt me  you